[Music]
Hello, welcome to Chat in the Arena, your
weekly podcast where we exchange
ideas about content we've read,
listened to, and watched, always bringing a
product/PR discussion perspective. I'm Artur, and
for the first time on the show, I'm the one who's got the
flu. I'm... The World Turns, right?
And the fool
spins. There's a Brazil game. Dorival Diola
begins the Dorival Diola era. We're
recording on Monday, right? By Wednesday
we'll already know if this will be good
or bad, right? We'll already be sad, right?
We're still sad, right? Because of what we've
seen so far... But anyway, in
today's program we're going to talk about
AI strategies, when it makes sense to
integrate with more than one model, where to
start, and things like that. And we'll
even do a
deep dive into what Apple is doing
with AI too. That's it. But before we
talk about AI, there's a little plug of the week: there's an
AI course. We're going to start promoting AI, right?
There's always that little plug this
week, the boss went crazy! So there will be... that's it, there will be a
course on
critical and analytical thinking with me and Dudu.
This week, this Saturday,
you'll be hearing this on
Wednesday, you'll still have two days
to buy. We've been warning you for a month and a
half, but we
know people like to buy at the
last minute, so we're going to
give you a little leeway here because the boss
went crazy! So, normally the
discount is 15% here in the
description, but today, only this week, there
will be a 25% discount! 1/4 of the
price here! Crazy! São João promotion,
June festival promotion! And so, on
June 29th, this Saturday, it will be
online and live, and on July 6th, which is
next Saturday, it will be in person here
in São Paulo, at the
PR Carena office, at Juus's office. And of
course, there's also one on
July 20th, in a month! So, there's still
time, but secure yours soon because it's
almost in the third batch already! The deal
with Efren and Ikira will be there too,
Miriam will also be there.  A
little bit about the tricks of...
so that's it, take advantage of the discount. Now
let's get to the agenda. Let's go!
[Music]
Okay, we're going to talk a little bit about
the strategies of... and a
recent article from Apple Insider came out and they
were talking about... well, Apple
made a deal with OpenAI to have
GPT chat integrated into iOS. We already
talked about this two episodes ago, if
you haven't watched or listened yet, press
play. But one of Apple's biggest markets
is China, and it won't work to have
a US company there. Especially
now that OpenAI has a guy who
was from NS on the board, right?
So, it's not a US company,
right? A company whose core
business is data collection and processing,
right? So, they are in
negotiations with Baidu and Alibaba,
but nothing is finalized. However,
the Chinese market is extremely important for Apple,
so they are looking for
another company, which one will be
behind it,
since other companies in China already have their
native systems
using it quite a lot.  ...and so on, it's Xiaomi and
Hiway, right? Mainly, yes, yes,
but actually, we brought this
news to delve a little
deeper into what we're talking about when we're talking
about product development, right?
Strategy, in the end, and the
product development that's behind it... let's
make some comments here beforehand
about Apple and China, because we only
talked about it at the WWDC program, and it's been
about two weeks since then, right? And
much more information has come out. So I think one
thing we talked about at the
Openi integration program, which became
clearer in the
following days, was that in fact, a good
part of the models are proprietary to
Apple. We talked about the things that
would run on the device, and what will run on the
device are proprietary models; what
will run on Apple's servers,
when necessary, are also
proprietary models. And only as a last
resort, for cases that require
more real-world knowledge, will
they use Openi modules. This
triggered a whole discussion on the internet:
Who's winning what with this?
Because if you think that Google
pays some...  Tens of billions a year
for Apple to be the main search engine
there, right? OpenG, in principle, isn't
paying Apple anything, so
OpenG gains more users, let's say,
but doesn't gain data for training,
so that question remained. And a report came out
today that Apple
is now talking to MetaTotal to
also implement the
possibility of using MetaTotal's models.
It seems like a path where
eventually they will charge someone to
be the main model. And then it will be like
when you open Safari, after
years of them releasing it, you can
select which is your default browser
there. So it may be a
future path, perhaps. And another point is
that we are very used to
talking about Western companies, we
end up not looking much at the East,
specifically China, right? But
recently, at least in
my Twitter bubble, there has been a lot of talk
about how China is now the largest
power in scientific production in the
world, and especially the models of
all these large companies, right? Artur
mentioned Baidu and Alibaba, which are in
talks with Apple, are models as
competent as the main models
that...  We use it here in the West, right?
When we look at PR for BMK, when
we look at PR capabilities, so I'll
even leave a link in the
description to a newsletter I
subscribe to that's exclusively
about... it's in China, so it's in English,
right? But the guy brings articles in
translated Chinese and Mandarin, right?
So you can get an idea of ​​everything that's
going on there, and I think it's very
interesting to stay informed about
what one of the two largest economies in the
world is doing in the
cutting-edge technology business. And if you can't,
if you don't know how to read
Mandarin, just use the GPT chat and it will
translate for you, or after you
learn there you'll see what's happening
in China and then you can use Chinese technology too
and ask them to send a translation
there as well. But anyway, any other points?
Oh Aira, I think not, let's talk about
strategy. So, in the end,
this led me to really focus on
where to start, how to
create, how to prepare the systems. How
much is it worth to be something
specific, how much is it worth,
like...  Preparing the system to receive
various... Anyway, I think it's a bit like that,
as [someone] said, we
talk a lot about it in the West,
especially about
chatbots, and much less about others like
Cloud, like Meta itself, right?
Meta, although it
occasionally makes a noise, but it
still talks little about some others,
and the idea is to talk a little about
that. And the comparison I
was thinking about here was mainly
in the Analytics part, because
we've already talked a lot here that it's
much more in the "how" than in the "in
fact, in the problem space," right? It's an enabler, right?
Exactly, exactly, and as we can say, it's like
the tool, right? It's kind of the
tool, like that. And then I was making
some analogies that I
was thinking about, like with mobile, right?
In the aspect of mobile, with Android, iOS,
etc., then the various other
hybrid languages, but
another one that I think serves very well for
this context we're going to talk
about, like how it's evolving very quickly and
you make this suit for one thing or
another, which is Analytics tools,
because in the past...  You didn't have a
lot of tools, right? You had
Google Analytics, it was the default, right? You
integrated the default there, and if you
used an app, you probably
had Firebase implemented there before
Google bought it, etc., and then all those
things, and then it ended up going back
to Google Analytics. I miss
my old Crash Analytics, what was it
called? It was Fabric, Fabric, the
beloved Fabric, which first went to
Twitter, right? Twitter bought it first,
then Google bought it, you remember that,
man? But anyway, and speaking of that
comparison, that's it. So, okay,
you're going to implement another
tool, man, you didn't need to keep
doing this switch, right? All the time, oh no,
now my data will be there. If you
had a very well-
consolidated data structure, maybe you
had some, maybe you had
Google Analytics, and I sent your
data to another one to have the
double-check, I sent it directly to your
data lake or something like that. That's
the top one, man, you
have to have the tool, but also send it
to the data lake to then cross-reference with
transactional data. And then
other tools started to emerge.  So, like,
segment, ah, that was the
intermediate layer. So you could plug into
as many analytics as you wanted. But
anyway, it wasn't something like when
you were going to solve, you'd say, "Okay, I'll have
several analytics here to do the
stitching when I need to," because it's
a duplication of work, right? Like,
imagine I'm going to send an event to
Firebase, to Mixpanel, and to Amplitude—that
's three SDCs for you to implement.
Then you'll eventually run into a
scenario where no number matches
another, and then you'll be trying to
tweak bits to find the most accurate number. It
wasn't productive, in fact, it was
n't. And when we talk a
little about the current world, the game changes
quite a bit, right? And I think the main thing
that changes for me is the rate at which the
models are evolving. Totally. And
when the models are evolving a lot,
you say, "Okay, I'll keep, I'll
use your expression, I'll keep
tweaking the bits here to make it
super fine for what I need," and
you might have cases where you'll go
much more towards that part of using
specific models and developing
specific models.  Improving
models versus using generics, and
when you get into the part about using
generics, if you stop to
think about the GPT chat itself,
for example, OpenFacebook, it has several
models that it lets you use
according to what you pay for, right? So
it has the 3.5, it has the for0, it has I don't
know what it is, we don't talk much about it here,
right? But we talk more about the
business, which is user face, yes, but
within the APIs there are several
different APIs for different models, for
different functionalities, and over
time they will even deprecate one or another
or add functionality, but for
those who make calls directly to the APIs, they
already have more visibility of this,
right? Yes, but even in the
customer facing itself, you can
select which model
you want, and I think this comes into play a lot
in this discussion, how much has
already passed, think that
in 2022, which is when OpenFacebook
was launched, how much has passed, I don't know,
less than 2 years, and how much can
we already achieve with the models?
Evolving so fast, it's much
easier to prepare the structure of
your product, right? You
can then switch to various
different models from different companies,
different contexts, which will
also have different values ​​and prices, and
adapt it to what makes the most
sense for your context. I
think there was an initial moment,
like with the logo on Chatchpt, that
was completely new,
with capabilities never seen
before, and everyone wanted to
experiment with what could and couldn't be
done. There was no
competition at the time, in fact, it was a "
to-use" model, so it made
perfect sense to do something
very specific, locked into a PR-op, there
was no other option. I think now, almost two
years later, we have
a very clear understanding that this is going to become a
commodity; the models are
commodities in a way. You'll have many
models provided by many companies, and
I tend to think that at some point
the difference
between them will stabilize. There won't be
super high differences this week,
but the new Antropic model came out
and it beats GPT.  So,
I think it's already
clear that there will be several
different business models, and that's where I get into
that whole thing about
service providers, what's core and what
's not core for your company, right? Because
if you have one core service provider, you have
none; if you have two, you have one. It was something
we talked about a lot back in the
Esporte Interativo days,
after you'd already left, because I was
looking a lot at streaming operations. For
streaming, I couldn't have just
one provider, I couldn't have
just one CDN provider, for example,
because if the CDN goes down for some
reason, I have to have another one to
serve it because that game is happening
live at that moment, right? So, the truth
is we had four different CDNs,
and we were exchanging them,
looking at which CDN best serves a particular
place. So, we had a huge
audience in the Northeast, and we had a
specific CDN that served it better there. How do
we achieve the best
cost balance between the CDNs we have here?
Trust comes into play, and the business models are
moving towards that and will increasingly
be.  In my opinion, you'll
have models that are good for
specific things that you'll use in
certain tasks. You'll have
different cost models that you
'll also use in certain tasks.
So we started in a time when it
was very expensive, let's say, and it made a lot of
sense to use a model just
because there weren't many options and because you
were still understanding the models. And we're
entering a phase of
optimization, as crazy as that
may seem given that everything has changed
so quickly, right? But it's like a startup where
you bring in a lot of people to
grow, and then you
optimize the processes and structure. I
think we're right in that phase with
artificial intelligence, and it makes perfect
sense to be somewhat
agnostic, to plug in what's
best and makes the most sense for
that context. And in that line of
plugging in what makes the most sense for the
context, that's it, right? To truly understand what
the core is, then, okay,
in the core I'll need to have
specific models, even making a
comparison like this: today, in my context at
Docket, Google isn't going to become an
expert in mobile registration, you know,
the document, it won't become...  A
specialist in mobile registration,
so, like, it's going to have
a series of other models there that
serve for various types of documents in a
more practical way. So, okay, now
you need a very
detailed analysis that will save you time, and
Docket will probably do that
better because we specialize
in this, right? We created
specific models for this and for various
other types of documents as well. But
we also wonder,
we created a model that,
before being specialized, is
generic, right? To understand documents
in our Pipeline and everything else, so why
not use it for other
types of documents that are more
standardized, etc., etc.? So I think it
gets into this discussion of
strategy, which is why we
even talked about strategy. What
is the strategy? We opted for the
opposite, for the more specific and
then the generic, but how many
others did the opposite, right?
They went to the generic first before
actually going to the specific, right? And it's difficult to
make this decision at this point in
history because you do
n't know how good these models will be,
enough for even
specific things that aren't
very, very, very specific.
Okay, so sometimes it's like the
famous 8020 principle, right? Pareto's principle. Sometimes you
'll have a generic Open Source model that,
for 80% of cases, even in the domain of
bureaucratic documents like Docket, will
work very well. And then there will be the 20%
where it won't be so good, and you'll
use other proprietary models that
are more expensive, but still for
those specific domains. It's very
difficult to know if this
will be good enough for
this, or not, because even the
Open Source guys say that.
Many of the things in the products that are
GPT-compatible here will die with the
evolution of the model itself. You know, to what extent
will the model be so good as to be so
generic, to what extent will there be
specialization? That's why
I think, once again, it's important to
have a structure
prepared to make the switch, whether it's a
specific model, a generic one,
or whatever comes into play
depending on the moment, and this even impacts
the type of professional you'll
need to hire for your team.
Not entirely. And while I was talking...
Here I was even thinking about ADI, right,
Artificial General Intelligence,
which is what people say, "Oh, but when
we reach ADI, will the models have the
capacity for reasoning like humans?"
And even when we get there,
think about it, every human being has a
certain level of intelligence, right? There
are still specializations, right? There are
human beings who are specialized in
medicine, there are human beings who are
specialized in technology, right? So, I don't know, maybe even
when
we get there, it will have an
average human level of intelligence. But for
specific tasks, you will still
need a specialization of the
models, right? So you will have a
very good artificial general intelligence, so a doctor can
take a document, a contract, read it and
understand roughly what it's a
contract about, what it's talking about, and so on, but
you will need a
specific model that knows how to create contracts
based on law xpto that work in
jurisdictions x and y and that protect parties
Y. So even when we get to
ADI, it's very likely that there will still be
these discussions of what I
do in the generic ADI model and what I
do in the specific model, right? And even
within the Docker scenario...  Just to
clarify, the gold isn't the model, right? The
gold is the data. The gold is the thing that only
you have access to in the end, which goes back
to what I said at the beginning: that
models will be commodities. So
everyone will have access to the same
model, but not everyone will have access to the
data to train that model in the best
way possible. This is something
Open Access itself did, and
Facebook has millions, billions,
etc., through partnerships.
Open Access did this with Reddit, and Facebook
has billions of users – that's
the data, right? That's the data that will be
valuable, as we even talked about in
the episode about the changing
aspect of ads. In the end,
even in the world, there's all this
synthetic data stuff, which is a
huge conversation about how we don't have
enough data created by humans anymore.
How do we train these models
with the models themselves generating their own
data? And that's something that has always been
discussed in machine learning,
even before this wave of AI,
which is the garb of in ga  Okay, so
if you generate garbage data at the input, you
'll generate garbage data at the output. If you have
models generating low-quality data,
the output of those models will also be
low-quality. That's it. But in the
end, I think to close this
block here, which was kind of nerdy,
this block was slightly
nerdy, slightly nerdy, nerdy
analysis here, but I think doing a
recap here, in the end, it's about your
strategy, if your product will have AI, and
if you're developing a product that
depends on AI or needs AI
to facilitate something, some
points that are interesting for you to
analyze are: first, how much
you actually need expert models, and
the other is to prepare your stack so you
can make this switch to
multiple models, whether it's pulling to
OpenAI, to Gini, to Cloud, to any
other that appears, and that this is with the
least possible effort, right? Because if every
time you need to spend a lot
more time developing to add another
model, you'll probably already be
behind, right? In terms of the speed at which things
emerge, you're already screwed. Exactly. And then I think there are
also other things, three items
to always think about, integration,
speed, and...  So, regarding the models and everything
else, and the cost associated with them, you already
have a good formula to understand and
see what will make sense for your
context. And going back to what
you said, remember that this is just another
tool, not something you do for the sake of doing it.
So, understand the impact on the
product experience you're actually working on.
When Artur talks about speed, there's
the development speed,
but there's also the speed of the
token outputs for your user. So, does it make
sense for your user to wait 20
seconds to receive an output?
Because sometimes that will drive their
decision. Sometimes you might have a
better model that takes longer, but
that makes sense for that case. Or you
have some cost constant, for
example. So, for a
very simple business, should I
be using the top-of-the-line model,
which is the most expensive on the market?
So how do you
get these user inputs into your product?
The input on the
quality of the model's output, right? So
let's suppose the most classic use case
here, the one that's on everyone's mind,
which is for customer service, support.  So, let's say,
how do you take that information at the
end, with CESAT, with something
that shows the service was actually good,
and how do you provide feedback on
that? And internally, how do you
understand the costs of that? It's not
just like in the
boom years of startups where
you just use things without looking at the
cost, so how do you balance
the cost and how do you understand it? And that's
part of what we bring here every
week, right? We like to
share the news, what's
new or what's being
improved for what you need.
So, for example, we'll talk about
the new
Antropic model, the Cloud 3.5 SONET, or SONET,
I think it's SONET. It was already a model
that I saw many of the newsletters I
subscribe to saying, "This is the
superior model to help with
writing activities, it's much better than the
OpenAI models for
creative operability and so on." And now
people are doing the same thing,
saying, "This new model is better
in code than the models of..."  Open A,
so since new things are coming out all the time,
how do you also surround yourself with
this information to know, "Hey, this
new model is better for this," how do
you do your own evaluations?
So there's a whole
academic discipline of model evaluation, but there's
also the part where you use it, your
user uses it and gives you feedback, so there's a
lot to consider there. And
again, flexibility at a time when
things move very fast can save
lives, right? Exactly. And so, if you
want to know even more about the behind-the-
scenes of building a product,
don't forget, boss, you've gone crazy! There's a 25%
discount on the link in the description, and on
July 20th there will be another edition
of the AI ​​course for PMs! Damn,
that was the contextualized announcement, right?
Targeted, that the guy who stayed listening until here is
interested in the subject, right?
At least listening to us talk for
half an hour
[Music]
here, and let's take advantage, let's talk
more about AI, let's... we haven't even talked about it yet, right?
Let's make this program dedicated
and let's do a round of news about
what happened in the last few days, let's go!
First thing, it's a
new company, Open A, right? Every week there is...
This time it's William Severn, who was
the mastermind behind
Sama's exit from Game of Thrones. He
founded a new company, SSI
Safe Super Intelligence, and
basically it's just another AI company, but
he says it won't have a
consumer-facing product, that they'll be
focused on security, on achieving
AI. To me, it's more of a
research lab. They're building a lab, which is what
they wanted to do at Open, but
Open became something else. And so they created
one, and they'll certainly get
good funding for it. And the
more people working in the domain, the better,
that's the truth. But there was a phrase
there that I felt was a hint of a
dig at Open, right? It was when they
said that
SSI is our mission, our name, and
our roadmap because that's our
focus, our team, our investors, and
our business model, all
aligned to achieve Safe Super
Intelligence. So it's written there,
roadmap. Every producer knows that the
roadmap is there. For what? To be changed.
So you can't trust any of this stuff.  We
have more
news, man! Open is fresh, right?
I mean, it's fresh today, Monday, when
we're recording, but Open has
bought another company now, right?
What's the name again? It's
Multi, which used to be called
Remotion, and they bought
another company about three days
ago, Rock
City. I think it's Rock Set.
So, having cash on hand is good, right? It allows them to
buy others. And this one from Multi,
specifically, from what they said, was an
acquisition, right? The one from Rock Set was a
content indexing platform, right? And
real-time information. I even saw
some people saying, "Ah, it has all the
hallmarks of technology to do something
similar to Microsoft's Recall in
Windows, right?" And it
also has a whole enterprise approach, offering
enterprise solutions. We'll see more, man. I've talked about it
at
least a few times, right? But about the new
Antropic model here, the Cloud 3.5 SONET.
So I don't know if there's much more to
say, but it's a new model that beat
GPT 4 for, I think that's the news, right? The
buzz was...  It was because for the first
time the model passed the "for now" and so on,
exactly, and man, it's sad because these
Anthropic models aren't
accessible in Brazil, right? You can
access them via PO, but you can't
access them directly from there, and that's what I
commented on, several of the guys I read
saying that it's still very good,
especially for
writing and coding activities. There was something
I found very interesting, which is
Artifacts, a tool they
released as a Beta along with the
model, which is kind of a workspace
along with the chat interface. And I
think the best way is to look on
Twitter and YouTube to get an
overview, but I think the coolest thing is in the
code part, for example,
you can interact with the code
it's generating. So there are several
classic cases, people asking
to build a game, like Snake, the
classic snake game. There was a guy
who made a prototype of Doom with
artificially generated levels, and with the
chat interface, for example, you would need to
copy that code, put it in VS
Code, compile it, run it, it's not
running directly, you  It can interact, and
that even helps in the process of
iterating over the code, right? So there's
that, and there's also the cost issue. I
think I saw some tweets
saying it was four or five times
cheaper than the Openi model.
So, going back to what we talked about regarding
costs, it could be a B option. It's
available from some vendors, it's on
Amazon if I'm not mistaken, I think it's also
available via Google Cloud. So, that's
it. And I think to close this
news roundup, it's a simple piece of news:
Apple has the Apple
Developer Academy program, right? And now they've
included the AI ​​part as well, and it's
coming to Brazil, anyway, I think it
'll be in the second half of the year. And
I think the interesting thing about this is that, from an
Apple perspective, it's good to have
more people developing
on their platform from an early age, which is why they created this program. But I think
this is another door they've opened early on,
showing
how interested they are in
this AI context. So they're not
just going to teach technologies,
how to code in Swift, things like that.  But
also, I've already learned about
[Music], so
let's go to the products of the
week, which we haven't
talked about in a while, right? It's been a while since we
talked, so let's start, since you've already
mentioned it, what's your product
of the week? Man, my product of the week
is the pregnancy app, but look, it's
Daddy Arthur, right? Daddy Arthur, right?
Because it's a really
cool app, it's a Philips app. But it's
really cool because it lets you, man,
but it lets you, you know, track what's going on, what
's expected for the week,
what's happening, what
size the baby is, you can
select it there, you want to see
its size, if it were a fruit, if it were
an animal. I've seen several screenshots of this
app on the internet, man, now I opened it
here to see. Man, it's really cool, it's really cool,
and but I'm going to make a
special mention here for one that I've already talked about a
few times, which is Riban Meta, right?
Man, they released an update this
week, and now
one of the things I've talked about a lot is that
the videos are bigger,
right?  Having the ability to record videos
now, videos can be up to 3
minutes long, so that's already better, right? Not
that you're going to be making 3-
minute videos all the time, but it really reduces the time.
You have to
press that little button every minute, right? That's
great, man. I'm biased,
but I've been following it for a while, and it's been very much like
OpenA and the
tools in general. The guys at
Facebook are also working on it because, man, every now
and then, just this year, so many updates
they've already released. The thing
is evolving. You posted on the
Disney link and Marcel even commented, "Wow,
celebrating the feature of automatically saving things to your
phone is a joke, right?"
They're removing features to
then put in the basics, the people at
Facebook... but it's that thing, the basics are
brilliant, right?
I thought
Marcel's comment on your push was good because I was
thinking about what we have to
consider, as
product people, what's essential
for this to work? And if you think about it,
automatically saving things isn't
essential, in fact, it's an
improvement of life, but no.  It's
essential. So it makes perfect sense
not to do it right away and do it later, you
know? It's not the same as in the beginning, you had to have your
phone open, the
app open to take
pictures, now you don't need to anymore. It
might seem very
simple, but in everyday
experience, everything changes, right? And it's difficult to
make these choices about what's essential.
Alice, who was our guest on the
last edition of Pect Hero (for those who haven't
heard it yet, listen), used to
provoke a lot of thought, like, "Okay, but
is this really necessary?" Like, "The
person can't use what we
want to deliver in terms of value if they don't have this."
This makes us reflect on, "Ah, maybe it's
not really that." And what was
yours? Mine is a two-in-one, which is the
same, same company, same product, which is
Buscapé and Zoom. So I'm
moving, right? And I'm buying things for the
house, appliances, furniture, that kind of thing, and
Buscapé and Zoom have
been a lifesaver, not only for
comparing prices between different
stores but also for seeing the price history,
right? So there are things you're not
used to.  So, when buying, like, man, I don't
know how many years ago I bought a
refrigerator, so I'm not really up-to-date on
refrigerator price trends. To
open Amazon and see if something
is cheap or expensive, you know? And it's really cool that
they give a price trend for
the last 40 days, last 60 days,
last 3 months, so that helps a lot.
And they also have
cashback, so they have cashbacks at
specific stores, even pretty good ones.
For example, there was 15% cashback at the LG store yesterday, so it's been helping a lot with the
new house purchases. Very good. I'm waiting for an invitation to the
Open House, huh? Let me change
first, man. Let me settle down
first. Well, our listeners here, our
listeners always send in suggestions. Cloves sent in
Invisible, which is basically a little
thing where you put an
application on your Mac so you can also
talk to the Mac and it does things. It's called
xGPT. But anyway, without the xGPT, it's GPT
rapper. Nana sent in Canva, Miria
sent in iFood, but specifically...  The
feature to show the market list
is of the type that I think
someone else already sent this before, I don't
remember now, but I also
have this vague memory. Karina
sent the Garmin Connect feature, which has also been
sent here before. Eduardo
sent R Studio, for
those who code in those
different languages. Bob sent Spotify and
he said that after WhatsApp it was the
best app, the best app
ever invented in history. It's the money, it's
the money, as I already said, that
I pay the most in
monthly fees, it's my Spotify, man, me too, me too, you even
mentioned paying,
I even remembered. Do you remember when
WhatsApp started, it cost R$1, I remember
at the time of the iPhone, 99 cents, 99
cents, wow, man. I remember I
got it once, I had an iPhone 3G at the
time, this was 2011. And then they made it
free once, I
got it back then and that was it.
Glauco sent HBO Max, he said that it
's not HBO anymore, right?  Maxx
said he only downloaded it again
to watch House of Dragon, it's not very
hyped, huh? House of Dragon is flopping,
and Lucas sent a picture, which is an
app for you to buy, and it's
specifically the
recurring Bitcoin purchase feature. Anyway, guys,
crypto, right? We hardly ever
talk about crypto here on the show, right? I
'm... well, we're already talking about... it's the... it's the... it's the... it's the... it's... it's... we're
talking about something that has
actual utility,
right? That's my comment about crypto.
So with that, with that, we're going to
end the show, right?
[Music]
That's it.
Ah, so that's it, with that we end
another edition here of Papo na Arena. As
always, don't forget to
give us five stars and follow us
wherever you use podcasts,
YouTube, subscribe, Spotify, Apple Podcasts,
anywhere. Go there and follow us so
you'll be notified every time a
new podcast comes out, and interact in the polls
we post there. We put
polls on Spotify, right? Especially... But
even if you...  Didn't you hear over there? You can
vote because we said in the
previous program that we were going to bring the
results of the poll here. I went to look today and there was
only one answer in the poll.
So you're not interacting in the
polls.
As long as there's no interaction, we won't
bring it. Interact in the polls. We're
going to think here about what
today's poll will be because I'm not ready to
say now what it will be. Sort it out in your
head. We can ask if
people are using any other model
besides... that's it. Good, good. We'll put some
options there. Have you frequently used
any other model, be it
J, Cloud itself, etc.? Anyway, there are the options there.
And follow us on social media, right? @x @ur
close comk on Instagram, on Twitter, on
Trads, on LinkedIn, and where we're
hosted @productArena, also on
all networks. And next week there's more,
right Artur? Next week there's more. I hope my
voice isn't strange and nasal.
And next week we'll be back, and I'll
tell you what the fruit
or sweet of the week is, which is what we bring every week.  That's
right, my daughter's name is A. We've
already decided on the name, so I'll tell you
every week now what her size is. That's it, see you
next week. Thanks everyone!